[Music]
they're loud shiny brightly-colored and
impossible to miss a quick glance and
they might look like lowriders but it's
their iconic elbow wheels high-gloss
candy paint and over-the-top stereo
systems that set them apart in the world
of custom automobiles these are slabs
said to be an acronym for slow route and
bangin slabs are a type of modified car
that originated in the city of Houston
their looks can be traced to the over
extravagant rides featured in the 1970s
blaxploitation films and a number of
mainstream movies too for those looking
to learn more about slabs there's only
one person to talk to Houston native and
slab aficionado Langston Wilkins
I'm a folklorist ethnomusicologist
researcher and writer and I've been
researching and writing about slab
culture for the last several years slabs
emerged in Houston Texas after many
communities in the mid 1980s more
specifically it emerged in the streets
this was the mid 1980s during the crack
era some young men were you know getting
relatively wealthy selling drugs and
they used slab as a way to show off
their success while also using it as an
artistic out but in the early 1990s slab
kind of moved out of that experience and
became part of the local hip-hop culture
and that's when the slab scene really
expanded and grew so what makes a
slap-ass slap-ass lab is typically an
odor modeled large-bodied
American today the Cadillac Lincoln
automobile etc and it's embellished or
outfitted with various types of body
additions the first and most important
one being the rims cost lingers or
elbows those are those comb-like rims
that poke out pretty far on the trunk
you have what's called a fifth wheel
which is a rim that's cut in half and
you closed in the fiberglass casing
also explosive stereo systems that you
know rattle or shake the car and shake
the surroundings when listening into rap
music and within the trunk you often
have what's called trunk displays which
are neon or sometimes glass signs that
convey particular messages to
communities with such a distinguished
appearance overt style at potential for
expression it's no wonder
Houston's wide collection of hip-hop
artists have embraced a slab culture
Jose slabs are the visual element of
Houston hip-hop culture
it's like graffiti or fashion in other
scenes slabs are a form of material
culture that illuminates the values
attitudes and ideas of the local hip-hop
community I think it's the swingers that
separates lab from other custom car
cultures that's why I've talked about so
much but beyond that I will say that
it's the larger hip-hop community larger
Houston hip-hop community that makes
labs special Houston hip-hop is marked
by a slow sound a psychedelic music its
atmospheric music and we see all of
those characteristics in Slab culture
slabs are meant to be driven really
really slow so that writers commonly
weave in and out of lanes when driving
their cars so slab isn't just a type of
car
it's an entire experience and it's an
entire culture so slab it certainly
special
[Music]